[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
DAVID SONTAG: OK, so
then today's lecture
is going to be about data
set shifts, specifically
how one can be robust
to data set shift.
Now, this is the topic
that we've been alluding to
throughout the semester.
And the setting that I want
you to be thinking about
is as follows.
You're a data scientist
working at, let's say,
Mass General
Hospital, and you've
been very careful in setting
up your machine learning task
to make sure that the
data is well specified,
the labels that you're trying
to predict are well specified.
You train on a valid--
you train on your training data,
you test it on a held-out set,
you see that the model
generalizes well,
you do chart review to
make sure what you're
predicting is actually what
you think you're predicting,
and you even do prospective
deployment where you then
let your machine
learning algorithm drive
some clinical decision
support, and you'd
see things are working great.
Now what?
What happens after this stage
when you go to deployment?
What happens when
your same model
is going to be used
not just tomorrow
but also next week, the
following week, the next year?
What happens if your model,
which is working well
at this one hospital, then
wants to-- then there's
another institution,
say, maybe Brigham
and Women's Hospital,
or maybe UCSF,
or some rural hospital
in the United States
wants to use the
same model, will it
keep working in this "short
term to the future" time period
or in a new institution?
That's the question which
we're going to be talking
about in today's lecture.
And we'll be talking
about how one
can deal with data set shift
of two different varieties.
The first variety is adversarial
perturbations to data,
and the second variety is
data due to-- the data that
changes for natural reasons.
Now, the reason why
it's not at all obvious
that your machine learning
algorithm should still
work in the setting is because
the number one assumption
we make when we do
machine learning
is that your training
distribution, your training
data, is drawn from the same
distribution as your test data.
So if you now go to a setting
where your data distribution
has changed, even if you've
computed your accuracy using
your held-out data
and it looks good,
there's no reason
that should continue
to look good in this new
setting, where the data
distribution has changed.
A simple example of what it
means for a data distribution
to change might be as follows.
Suppose that we
have as input data,
and we're trying to
predict some label, which
maybe meant something like,
why if a patient has--
or will be newly diagnosed
with type 2 diabetes,
and this is an
example which we--
which we talked about when we
introduce risk stratification,
you learn a model
to predict y from x.
And now suppose you go
to a new institution
where their definition of
what type 2 diabetes means
has changed.
For example, maybe they don't
actually have type 2 diabetes
coded in their data, maybe
they only have diabetes
coded in their data,
which is lumping together
both type 1 and type
2 diabetes, type 1
being what's usually
juvenile diabetes
and is actually a very distinct
disease from type 2 diabetes.
So now the notion of what
diabetes is is different.
Maybe the use case is
also slightly different.
And there's no
reason, obviously,
that your model, which was used
to predict type 2 diabetes,
would work for that new label.
Now, this is an example
of a very type--
of a type of data set
shift which is perhaps
for you obvious nothing
should work in the setting
because here the distribution
of P of y given x changes,
meaning even if you have
the same individual,
your distribution P(y)
given x in, let's say,
the distribution P(0) and the
distribution P of y given x
and P(1), where this is, let's
say, one institution, this
is another, these now are
two different distributions
if the meaning of the
label has changed.
So for the same person, there
might be different distribution
over what y is.
So this is one
type of data shift.
And a very different
type of data
set shift is where we assume
that these two are equal.
And so that would,
for example, rule out
this type of data set shift.
But rather what changes is P of
x from location 1 to location--
to location 2.
And this is the type of data set
shift which will be focused on
in today's lecture.
It goes by the name
of covariate shift.
And let's look at two
different examples of that.
The first example would be of
an adversarial perturbation.
And so we've-- you've all seen
the use of convolutional neural
networks for image
classification problems.
This is just one illustration
of such an architecture.
And with such an
architecture, one
could then attempt to do all
sorts of different object
classification or image
classification tasks.
You could take as input
this picture of a dog, which
is clearly a dog.
And you could modify
it just a little bit.
Just add in a very
small amount of noise.
What I'm going to
do is now I'm going
to create a new image which
is that original image.
Now with every single
pixel, I'm going
to add a very small epsilon in
the direction of that noise.
And what you get out
is this new image,
which you could stare at
however long you want,
you're not going to able
to tell the difference.
Basically to the
human eye, these two
look exactly identical.
Except when you take your
machine learning classifier,
which is trained on
original unperturbed data,
and now apply it
to this new image,
it's classified as an ostrich.
And this observation
was published
in a paper in 2014 called
"Intriguing properties
of neural networks."
And it really kickstarted
a huge surge of interest
in the machine
learning community
on adversarial perturbations
to machine learning.
So asking questions, if you
were to perturb inputs just
a little bit, how
does that change
your classifier's output?
And could that be used to attack
machine learning algorithms?
And how can one
defend against it?
By the way, as an
aside, this is actually
a very old area of research.
And even back in the land
of linear classifiers,
these questions
had been studied.
Although I won't get
into it in this course.
So this is a type of data
set shift in the sense
that what we want is that this
should still be classified
as an ostrich-- as a dog.
So the actual label
hasn't changed.
We would like this distribution
over the labels, given
the perturbed into it,
to be slightly different,
except that now the
distribution of inputs
is a little bit
different because we're
allowing for some noise to be
added to each of the inputs.
And in this case, the noise
actually isn't random,
it's adversarial.
And towards the end
of today's lecture,
I'll give you an example
of how one can actually
generate the
adversarial image, which
can change the classifier.
Now, the reason
why we should care
about these types of
things in this course
are because I expect
that this type of data
set shift, which is not at
all natural, it's adversarial,
is also going to start
showing up in both computer
vision and non-computer vision
problems in the medical domain.
There was a nice paper by Sam
Finlayson, Andy Beam, and Isaac
Kohane recently, which
presented several different case
studies of where these
problems could really
arise in health care.
So, for example, here
what we're looking at
is an image
classification problem
arising from dermatology.
You're given as input an image.
For example, you would like
that this image be classified
as an individual having
a particular type of skin
disorder, a nevus, and
this other image, melanoma.
And what one can see is that
with a small perturbation
of the input, one
can completely swap
the label that would be assigned
to it from one to the other.
And in this paper,
which we're going
to post as optional
readings for today's course,
they talk about how one
could maliciously use
these algorithms for benefit.
So, for example, imagine that
a health insurance company now
decides in order to reimburse
for an expensive biopsy
of a patient's skin,
a clinician or a nurse
must first take a
picture of the disorder
and submit that picture
together with the bill
for the procedure.
And imagine now that the
insurance company were
to have a machine
learning algorithm be
an automatic check, was this
procedure actually reasonable
for this condition?
And if it isn't, it
might be flagged.
Now, a malicious user could
perturb the input such
that it would, despite the
patient having perhaps even
completely normal-looking
skin, could nonetheless
be classified by a
machine learning algorithm
as being abnormal in
some way, and thus
perhaps could get reimbursed
by that procedure.
Now, obviously
this is an example
of a nefarious setting
where we would then
hope that such an
individual would be caught
by the police, sent to jail.
But nonetheless, what we
would like to be able to do
is build checks and balances
into the system such
that that couldn't even
happen because to a human
it's obvious that you
shouldn't be able to trick--
trick anyone with such a
very minor perturbation.
So how do you build
algorithms that
could also be not
tricked as easily
as humans wouldn't be tracked?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question
DAVID SONTAG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For any
of these samples,
did the attacker need
access to the network?
Is there a way to
[? attack it? ?]
DAVID SONTAG: So the question
is whether the attacker needs
to know something about
the function that's
being used for classifying.
There are examples of both what
are called white box and black
box attacks, where in one
setting you have access
to the function and
other settings you don't.
And so both have been
studied in the literature,
and there are results
showing that one
can attack in either setting.
Sometimes you might need
to know a little bit more.
Like, for example,
sometimes you need
to have the ability to query
the function a certain number
of times.
So even if you don't know
exactly what the function is,
like you don't know the
weights of the neural network,
as long as you can query
it sufficiently many times,
you'll be able to construct
adversarial examples.
That would be one approach.
Another approach
would be, oh, maybe we
don't know the function,
but we know something
about the training data.
So there are ways to go about
doing this even if you don't
perfectly know the function.
Does that answer your question?
So what about a
natural perturbation?
So this figure just
pulled from lecture 5
when we talked about
non-stationarity
in the context of risk
stratification, that's
just to remind you here the
x-axis is time, that y-axis is
different types of
laboratory test results
that might be ordered,
and the color denotes
how many of those
laboratory tests
were ordered in a certain
population at a point in time.
So what we would expect to
see if the data was stationary
is that every row would
be a homogeneous color.
But instead what we see is
that there are points in time,
for example, a few month
integrals over here,
when suddenly it looks like, for
some of the laboratory tests,
they were never performed.
That's most likely
due to a data problem,
or perhaps the feed of data from
that laboratory test provider
got lost, there were
some systems problem.
But they're also going
to be settings where,
for example, a
laboratory test is never
used until it's suddenly used.
And that might be because
it's a new test that
was just invented or
approved for reimbursement
at that point in time.
So this is an example
of non-stationarity.
And, of course, this
could also result
in changes in your
data distribution,
such as what I described
over there, over time.
And the third example
is when you then
go across institutions,
wherein, of course,
both the language that might
be used-- you might think
of a hospital in
the United States
versus a hospital in China, the
clinical notes will be written
in completely different
languages, that'll
would be an extreme case.
And a less extreme case might
be two different hospitals
in Boston where the
acronyms or the shorthand
they use for some clinical
terms might actually
be different because
of local practices.
So, what do we do?
This is all a setup.
And for the rest of the
lecture, what I'll talk about
is first, very
briefly, how one can
build in population-level checks
for has something changed.
And then the bulk
of today's lecture,
we'll be talking about how
to develop transfer learning
algorithms and how one
could think about defenses
to adversarial attacks.
So before I show you that
first slide for bullet one,
I want to have a
bit of discussion.
You've suddenly done that
thing of learning machine
learning algorithm
in your institution,
and you want to know,
will this algorithm
work at some other institution?
You pick up the phone, you
call up your collaborating data
scientists at another
institution, what
are the questions that
you should ask them
when we're trying to
understand, will your algorithm
work there as well?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What kind of
lab test information
they collect [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID SONTAG: So
what type of data
do they have on their
patients, and do they
have similar data types
or features available
for their patient population?
Other ideas, someone who
hasn't spoken in the last two
lectures, maybe someone
in the far back there,
people who have
their computer out.
Maybe you with your
hand in your mouth
right there, yeah, you
with your glasses on.
Ideas.
[STUDENT LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: Sorry, can
you repeat the question?
DAVID SONTAG: You want me
to repeat the question?
The question was as follows.
You learn your machine learning
algorithm at some institution,
and you want to apply it
now in a new institution.
What questions should you
ask of that new institution
to try to assess whether your
algorithm will generalize
in that new institution?
AUDIENCE: I guess it depends on
your problem you're looking at,
like whether you're
trying to learn
possible differences
in your population,
if you're requiring data with
particular [INAUDIBLE] use.
So I'd envision it
that you'd want to,
like are your machines
calibrated [INAUDIBLE]??
Do they use techniques
to acquire the data?
DAVID SONTAG: All right.
So let's break down each of
the answers that you gave.
The first answer
that you gave was,
are there differences
in the population?
What would be an exa--
someone else now,
what are we an example of a
difference in a population?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Age
distribution You might
have younger people
in maybe Boston
versus like a
Massachusetts [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID SONTAG: So you
might have younger people
in Boston versus
older people who
are in Central Massachusetts.
How might a change
in age distribution
affect your ability of your
algorithms to generalize?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [? Possibly ?]
health patterns,
where young people are very
different from [INAUDIBLE] who
have some diseases that
are clearly more prevalent
in populations that are
older [? than you. ?]
DAVID SONTAG: Thank you.
So sometimes we might expect a
different just set of diseases
to occur for a younger
population versus an older
population.
So I type 2 diabetes,
hypertension,
these are diseases that are
often diagnosed when patients--
when individuals are
40s, 50s, and older.
If you have people
who are in their 20s,
you don't typically
see those diseases
in a younger population.
And so what that means is
if your model, for example,
was trained on a population
of very young individuals,
then it might not be able
to-- and suppose you're doing
something like
predicting future cost,
so something which is not
directly tied to the disease
itself, the features that
are predictive of future cost
in a very young population
might be very different from
features--
for predictors of cost in a
much older population because
of the differences in conditions
that those individuals have.
Now the second
answer that was given
had to do with calibration
of instruments.
Can you elaborate
a bit about that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I was thinking [? clearly ?]
in the colonoscopy space.
But if you're collecting--
so in that space,
you're collecting
videos of colons.
And so you can
have machines that
are calibrated very
differently, let's say
different light exposure,
different camera settings.
But you also have that
the GIs and physicians
have different techniques as
to how they explore the colon.
So the video data itself is
going to be very different.
DAVID SONTAG: So the
example that was given
was of colonoscopies
and data that might
be collected as part of that.
And the data that could be--
the data that could be collected
could be different for
two different reasons.
One, because the-- because
the actual instruments
that are collecting the data,
for example, imaging data,
might be calibrated a
little bit differently.
And a second reason might be
because the procedures that
are used to perform that
diagnostic test might be
different in each institution.
Each one will result in slightly
different biases to the data,
and it's not clear that
an algorithm trained
on one type of procedure
or one type of instrument
would generalize to another.
So these are all great examples.
And so when one reads a paper
from the clinical community
on developing a new risk
stratification tool, what
you will always
see in this paper
is what's known as "Table 1."
Table 1 looks a
little bit like this.
Here I pulled one
of my own papers
that was published in
JAMA Cardiology for 2016
where we looked at how to try
to find patients with heart
failure who are hospitalized.
And I'm just going to walk
through what this table is.
So this table is
describing the population
that was used in the study.
At the very top, it says these
are characteristics of 47,000
hospitalized patients.
Then what we've done is,
using our domain knowledge,
we know that this is a
heart failure population,
and we know that there are
a number of different axes
that differentiate patients
who are hospitalized
that have heart failure.
And so we enumerate over
many of the features
that we think are critical to
characterizing the population,
and we give
descriptive statistics
on each one of those features.
You always start with things
like age, gender, and race.
And so here, for example, the
average age was 61 years old,
this was, by the way, NYU
Medical School, 50.8% female,
11.2% Black, African-American,
17.6% of individuals
were on Medicaid, which
was a state-provided health
insurance for either disabled
or lower-income individuals.
And then we looked at quantities
like what types of medications
were patients on.
41% of-- 42% of
inpatient patients
were on something
called beta blockers.
31.6% of outpatients
were on beta blockers.
We then looked at things
like laboratory test results.
So one can look at the
average creatinine values,
the average sodium values
of this patient population.
And in this way,
it described what
is the population
that's being studied.
Then when you go to
the new institution,
that new institution receives
not just the algorithm,
but they also
receive this Table 1
that describes a population in
which the algorithm was learned
on.
And they could use that together
with some domain knowledge
to think through questions like
what we were eliciting-- what
I elicited from you
in our discussion
so that we could
think, is it actually--
does it make sense that
this model will generalize
to this new institution?
Are the reasons
why it might not?
And you could do that
even before doing
any prospective evaluation
on the new population.
So almost all of you should
have something like Table 1
in your project
write-ups because that's
an important part of any study
in this field is describing,
what is the population that
you're doing your study on?
You agree with me, Pete?
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
I would just at that Table 1,
if you're doing a case control
study, you will have
two columns that
show the distributions
in the two populations,
and then a p-value of how
likely those differences are
to be significant.
And if you leave that out, you
can't get your paper published.
DAVID SONTAG: I'll just
repeat Pete's answer
for the recording.
If you are-- this table is
for a predictive problem.
But if you're thinking about a
causal inference type problem,
where there's a notion of
different intervention groups,
then you'd be expected to
report the same sorts of things,
but for both the
case population,
the people who received,
let's say, treatment one,
and the control
population of people
who receive treatment zero.
And then you would be
looking at differences
between those populations as
well at the individual feature
level as part of the descriptive
statistics for that study.
Now, this-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this to
identify [? individually ?]
[? between ?] those peoples?
[INAUDIBLE] institutions to do
like t-tests on those tables--
DAVID SONTAG: To see
if they're different?
No, so they're always
going to be different.
You go to a new
institution, it's
always going to look different.
And so just looking to see
how something changed is not--
the answer's always
going to be yes.
But it enables a conversation
to think through, OK, this,
and then you might look--
you might use some
of the techniques
that Pete's going to talk about
next week on interpretability
to understand, well, what
is the model actually using.
Then you might
ask, oh, OK, well,
the model is using
this thing, which
makes sense in this population
but might not make sense
in another population.
And it's these two
things together
that make the conversation.
Now, this question
has really come
to the forefront in recent
years in close connection
to the topic that Pete
discussed last week on fairness
in machine learning.
Because you might ask
if a classifier is built
in some population, is
it going to generalize
to another population if that
population that has learned on
was very biased, for
example, it might
have been all white people.
You might ask, is
that classifier
going to work well in another
population that might perhaps
include people of
different ethnicities?
And so that has led to a concept
which was recently published.
This working draft that I'm
showing the abstract from
was just a few weeks ago called
"Datasheets for data sets."
And the goal here
is to standardize
the process of
describing-- of eliciting
the information about what is it
about the data set that really
played into your model?
And so I'm going to walk
you through very briefly
just through a
couple of elements
of what an example data set for
a datasheet might look like.
This is too small
for you to read,
but I'll blow up one
section in just a second.
So this is a
datasheet for a data
set called Studying Face
Recognition in an Unconstrained
Environment.
So it's for computer
vision problem.
There are going to be a
number of questionnaires,
which this paper that I
point you to outlines.
And you as the model developer
go through that questionnaire
and fill out the
answers to it, so
including things about
motivation for the data
set creation
composition and so on.
So in this particular instance,
this data set called Labeled
Faces in the Wild was created to
provide images that study face
recognition in an unconstrained
[INAUDIBLE] settings,
where image characteristics
such as pose, elimination,
resolution, focus
cannot be controlled.
So it's intended to be
real-world settings.
Now, one of the most
interesting sections
of this report that one should
release with the data set
has to do with how was the
data preprocessed or cleaned?
So, for example,
for this data set,
it walks through the
following process.
First, raw images were
obtained from the data set,
and it consisted of
images and captions that
were found together with
that image in news articles
or around the web.
Then there was a face detector
that was run on the data set.
Here were the parameters of the
face detector that were used.
And then remember, the goal
here is to study face detection.
And so-- so one has to
know, how were the--
how were the labels determined?
And how would one, for
example, eliminate if there
was no face in this image?
And so there they described
how a face was detected and how
a region was determined to not
be a face in the case that it
wasn't.
And finally, it describes
how duplicates were removed.
And if you think
back to the examples
we had earlier in the
semester from medical imaging,
for example in
pathology and radiology,
similar data set constructions
had to be done there.
For example, one would
go to the PAC System
where radiology images
are stored, one would--
one would decide which images
are going to be pulled out,
one would go to
radiography reports
to figure out how do we
extract the relevant findings
from that image,
which would give
the labels for that predictive--
for that learning task.
And each step there will
incur some bias and some--
which one then needs to
describe carefully in order
to understand what
might the bias
be of the learned classifier.
So I won't go into more
detail on this now,
but this will also be
one of the suggested
readings for today's course.
And it's a fast read.
I encourage you to go through
it to get some tuition for what
are questions we might want
to be asking about data sets
that we create.
And for the rest
of this semester--
for the rest of the
lecture today, I'm
now going to move on to
some more technical issues.
So we have to do it.
We're doing machine
learning now.
The populations
might be different.
What do we do about it?
Can we change the
learning algorithm
in order to hope that your
algorithm might transfer better
to a new institution?
Or if we get a little bit of
data from that new institution,
could we use that
small amount of data
from the new institution or a
future time point in the future
to retrain our model to
do well in that slightly
different distribution?
So that's the whole field
of transfer learning.
So you have data drawn from one
distribution on p of x and y,
and maybe we have a little bit
of data drawn from a different
distribution q of x,y.
And under the covariate
shift assumption,
I'm assuming that q(x,y) is
equal to q of x times p of y
given x, namely that the
conditional distribution of y
given x hasn't changed.
The only thing that
might have changed
is your distribution over x.
So that's what the covariate
shift assumption would assume.
So suppose that we
have some small amount
of data drawn from the
new distribution q.
How could we then
use that in order
to perhaps retrain our
classifier to do well
for that new institution?
So I'll walk through four
different approaches to do so.
I'll start with
linear models, which
are the simplest to
understand, and then I'll
move on to deep models.
The first approach to something
that you've seen already
several times in this course.
We're going to
think about transfer
as a multi-task learning
problem, where one of the tasks
has much less data
than the other task.
So if you remember when
we talked about disease
progression modeling,
I introduced
this notion of
regularizing the weight
vectors so that they could
be close to one another.
At that time, we were
talking about weight vectors
predicting disease
progression in different time
points in the future.
We could use exactly
the same idea here,
where you take your classifier,
your linear classifier that
was trained on a
really large corpus,
I'm going to call that--
I'm going to call the weights
of that classifier w old,
and then I'm going to solve a
new optimization problem, which
is minimizing over the weights
w that minimizes some loss.
So this is where your training--
your new training data come in.
So I'm going to assume that
the new training get D is
drawn from the q distribution.
And I'm going to add on a
regularization that asks that w
should stay close to w old.
Now, if the amount of
data you have-- if D,
the data from that new
institution, was very large,
then you wouldn't need this at
all because you would be able
to just--
you would be able to ignore
the classifier that you learned
previously and just
refit everything
to that new institution's data.
Where something like this
is particularly valuable
is if there was a small
amount of data set shift,
and you only have a very
small amount of labeled data
from that new
institution, then this
would allow you to
change your weight
vector just a little bit.
So if this coefficient
was very large,
it would say that
the new w can't
be too far from the old w.
So it'll allow you to
shift things a little bit
in order to do well on the small
amount of data that you have.
So, for example, if there is
a feature which was previously
predictive, but that
feature is no longer
present in the new data
set, so, for example,
it's all identically zero,
then, of course, the new weight
vect--
the new weight for that feature
is going to be set to 0,
and that weight
you can think about
as being redistributed to
some of the other features.
Does this makes sense?
Any questions?
So this is the simplest
approach to transfer learning.
And before you ever try
anything more complicated,
always try this.
Uh, yep.
So the second approach is
also with a linear model,
but here we're no longer going
to assume that the features are
still useful.
So there might--
when you go from--
when you go from a--
your first institution, let's
say, I'm GH on the left,
you learn your model,
and you can apply it
to some new institution,
let's say, UCSF on the right,
it could be that there
is some really big change
in the feature set such that--
such that the original
features are not at all
useful for the new feature set.
And a really extreme
example of that
might be the setting that
I gave earlier when I said,
your model's trained on English,
and you're testing it out
in Chinese.
That would be an example--
if you use a bag of
words model, that
would be an example where
your model, obviously,
wouldn't generalize at all
because your features are
completely different.
So what would you
do in that setting?
What's the simplest
thing that you might do?
So you're taking a text
classifier learned in English,
and you want to
apply it in a setting
where that language is Chinese.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: Train on them.
DAVID SONTAG:
Translate, you said.
And there was another answer.
AUDIENCE: Or try train an RN.
DAVID SONTAG: Train
an RN to do what?
AUDIENCE: To translate.
DAVID SONTAG: Train
an RN-- oh, OK.
So assume that you
have some ability
to do machine translation, you
translate from English to--
from Chinese to English.
It has to be that direction
because the original classifier
was trained in English.
And then your new function
is the composition
of the translation and the
original function, right?
And then you can
imagine doing some fine
tuning if you had a
small amount of data.
Now, the simplest
translation function
might be just use a dictionary.
So you look up a
word, and if that word
has an analogy in
another language,
you say, OK, this
is the translation.
But there are always going to
be some words in your language
which don't have a
very good translation.
And so you might imagine that
the simplest approach would
be to translate, but
then to just drop out
words that don't
have a good analog
and force your classifier
to work with, let's say,
just the shared vocabulary.
Everything we're
talking about here
is an example of a
manually chosen decision.
So we're going to manually
choose a new representation
for the data such that we
have some amount of shared
features between the source
and target data sets.
So let's talk about
electronic health record 1
and electronic health record 2.
By the way, the slides that
I'll be presenting here
are from a paper
published in KDD
by Jan, Tristan, your
instructor, Pete,
and John Guttag.
So you have to go
two electronic health
records, electronic
health record 1,
electronic health record 2.
How can things change?
Well, it could be that the same
concept in electronic health
record 1 might be mapped
to a different encoding,
so that's like an
English-to-Spanish type
translation, in electronic
health record 2.
Another example
of a change might
be to say that some concepts
are removed, like maybe you
have laboratory test results
in electronic health record 1
but not in electronic
health record 2.
So that's why you see
an edge to nowhere.
Another change might be
there might be new concepts.
So the new institution
might have new types of data
that the old
institution didn't have.
So what do you do
in that setting?
Well, one approach
we would say, OK, we
have some small amount of
data from electronic health
record 2.
We could just train
using that and throw away
your original data from
electronic health record 1.
Now, of course, if you
only had a small amount
of data from the target
to distribution, then
that's going to be a very poor
approach because you might not
have enough data
to actually learn
a reasonable enough model.
A second obvious
approach would be,
OK, we're going to just train
on electronic health record 1
and apply it.
And for those concepts that
aren't present anymore,
so be it.
Maybe things won't
work very well.
A third approach, which we
were alluding to before when
we talked about
translation, would
be to learn a model just in
the intersection of the two
features.
And what this work
does, as they say,
we're going to manually
redefine the feature set
in order to try to find as
much common ground as possible.
And this is something
which really involves
a lot of domain knowledge.
And I'm going to be using
this as a point of contrast
from what I'll be talking about
in 10 or 15 minutes, where
I talk about how one could
do this without that domain
knowledge that we're
going to use here.
So the setting
that they looked at
is one of predicting outcomes,
such as in-hospital mortality
or length of stay.
The model which is going to be
used as a bag-of-events model.
So we will take a patient's
longitudinal history up
until the time of prediction.
We'll look at different
events that occurred.
And this study was
done using PhysioNet.
And MIMIC, for example, events
are encoded with some number,
like 5814 might
correspond to a CVP alarm,
1046 might correspond
to pain being present,
25 might correspond to the drug
heparin being given and so on.
So we're going to create one
feature for every event which
has some number--
which is encoded
with some number.
And we'll just say
1 if that event
has occurred, 0 otherwise.
So that's the representation
for a patient.
Now, because when one goes
though this new institution,
EHR2, the way that
events are encoded
might be completely different.
One won't be able to just
use the original feature
representation.
And that's the
English-to-Spanish example
that I gave.
But instead, what
one could try to do
is come up with a new feature
set where that feature
set could be derived from each
of the different data sets.
So, for example, since each
one of the events in MIMIC
has some text
description that goes
with it, event one corresponds
to ischemic stroke,
event 2, hemorrhagic
stroke, and so on,
one could attempt to map--
use that English
description of the feature
to come up with a way to map
it into a common language.
In this case, the
common language
is the UMLS, the
United Medical Language
System that Pete talked
about a few lectures ago.
So we're going to now say, OK,
we have a much larger feature
set where we've now
encoded ischemic stroke
as this concept,
which is actually
the same ischemic
stroke, but also
as this concept
and that concept,
which are more general
versions of that original one.
So this is just
general stroke, and it
could be multiple
different types of strokes.
And the hope is
that even if in--
even if the model doesn't--
even if some of these
more specific ones
don't show up in the
new institution's data,
perhaps some of the more general
concepts do show up there.
And then what you're
going to do is
you're going to learn your model
now on this expanded translated
vocabulary, and
then translate it.
And at the new
institution, you'll
also be using that
same common data model.
And that way one hopes
to have much more overlap
in your feature set.
And so to evaluate
this, the authors
looked at two different
time points within MIMIC.
One time point was when the
Beth Israel Deaconess Medical
Center was using electronic
health record called CareView.
And the second time point
was when that hospital
was using a different
electronic health
record called MetaVision.
So this is an example
actually of non-stationarity.
Now because of them using two
different electronic health
records, the encodings
were different.
And that's why
this problem arose.
And so we're going
to use this approach,
and we're going to then
learn a linear model
on top of this new encoding
that I just described.
And we're going to compare the
results by looking at how much
performance was lost due
to using this new encoding,
and how well we
generalize from one--
from one-- from the source
task to the target task.
And so here's the
first question,
which is, how much do we lose
by using this new encoding?
So as a comparison
point for looking
at predicting in-hospital
mortality, we'll look at,
what is the
predictive performance
if you're to just use an
existing, very simple risk
score called the SAPS score?
And that's this red line
where that y-axis here
is the area under the
ROC curve, and the x-axis
is how much time
in advance you're
predicting, so the
prediction gap.
So using this very simple score,
SAPS get somewhere between 0.75
and 0.80, area
under the ROC curve.
But if you were to use all
of the events data, which
is much, much richer than what
went into that simple SAPS
score, you would get the
purple curve, which is--
the purple curve, which is
SAPS plus the event data,
or the blue curve, which
is just the events data.
And you can see you
can get substantially
better predictive
performance by using
that much richer feature set.
The SAPS score has the
advantage that it's easier
to generalize because it's so
simple, those feature elements,
one could trivially translate
to any new EHR, either manually
or automatically, and thus
it'll always be a viable route.
Whereas this blue
curve, although it
gets better predictive
performance,
you have to really worry about
these generalization questions.
And the same story happens
in both of the source
task and the target task.
Now the second question
to ask is, well,
how much do you lose when you
use the new representation
of the data?
And so here looking at,
again, both of the two--
both EHRs, what we
see first in red
is the same red curvature-- is
the same as the blue curvature
on the previous slide.
It's using SAPS plus the item
IDs, so using all of the data.
And then the blue curve here,
which is a bit hard to see,
but it's right there,
it's substantially lower.
So that's what
happens if you now
use this new representation.
And you see that you
do lose something
by trying to find a
common vocabulary.
The performance
does get hit a bit.
But what's particularly
interesting is
when you attempt to generalize,
you start to see a swap.
So if we now--
so now the colors are
going to be quite similar.
Red here was at the
very top before.
So red is using the original
representation of the data.
Before it was at the very top.
Shown here is the training error
on this institution, CareView.
You see, there's so
much rich information
in the original
feature set that it's
able to do very good
predictive performance.
But once you attempt
to translate it,
so you train on CareView,
but you test on MetaVision,
then the test performance shown
here by this solid red line
is actually the worst
of all of the system.
So there's a substantial
drop in performance
because not all
of these features
are present in the new EHR.
On the other hand, when
the translated version,
despite the fact that it's
a little bit worse when
evaluated on the source,
it generalizes much better.
And so you see a significantly
better performance
that's shown by this
blue curve here when you
use this translated vocabulary.
There's a question.
AUDIENCE: So would you
train with full features?
So how do you apply [? with ?]
them if the other [? full ?]
features are-- you
just [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID SONTAG: So, you
assume that you have come up
with a mapping from the
features in both of the EHRs
to this common feature
vocabulary of QEs.
And the way that this mapping is
going to be done in this paper
is based on the text of the--
of the events.
So you take the text-based
description of the event,
and you come up with a
deterministic mapping
to this new UMLS-based
representation.
And then that's
what's being used.
There's no fine
tuning being done
in this particular example.
So I consider this to be a very
naive application of transfer.
The results are exactly what you
would expect the results to be.
And, obviously, a lot of work
had to go into doing this.
And there's a bit of creativity
in thinking that you should use
the English-based
description of the features
to come up with the
automatic mapping,
but the story ends there.
And so a question
which all of you
might have is, how
could you try to do
such an approach automatically?
How could we automatically
find representations-- new
representations of
the data that are
likely to generalize
from, let's say,
a source distribution to
a target distribution?
And so to talk about
that, we're going
to now start thinking
through representation
learning-based approaches,
of which deep models are
particularly capable.
So the simplest approach to
try to do transfer learning
in the context of, let's
say, deep neural networks,
would be to just chop off part
of the network and reuse that--
some internal representation of
the data in this new location.
So the picture looks a
little bit like this.
So the data might
feed in the bottom.
There might be a number
of convolutional layers,
some fully connected layers.
And what you decide
to do is you're
going to take this model that's
trained in one institution,
you chop it at some layer,
it might be, for example,
prior to the last
fully connected layer,
and then you're
going to take that--
take the new representation
of your data,
now the representation
of the data
is what you would get out
after doing some convolutions
followed by a single
fully connected layer,
and then you're going to take
your target distribution's
data, which you might only
have a small amount of,
and you learn a simple model on
top of that new representation.
So, for example, you might
learn a shallow classifier
using a support
vector machine on top
of that new representation.
Or you might add in some more--
a couple more layers of a deep
neural network, and then fine
tune the whole thing end to end.
So all of these have been tried.
And in some cases, one
works better than another.
And we saw already one example
of this notion in this course.
And that was when Adam
Yala spoke in lecture 13
about breast cancer
and mammography,
where in his approach he
said that he had tried both
taking a randomly
initialized classifier
and comparing that to what
would happen if you initialized
with a well-known
ImageNet-based deep neural
network for the problem.
And he had a really
interesting story that he gave.
In his case, he had enough
data that he actually
didn't need to initialize
using this pre-trained model
from ImageNet.
If he had just done a random
initialization, eventually--
and this x-axis,
I can't remember,
it might be hours of training
or epochs, I don't remember,
it's time--
eventually the
right initialization
gets to a very
similar performance.
But for his particular
case, if you
were to do a initialization with
ImageNet and then fine tune,
you get there
much, much quicker.
And so it was for the
computational reason
that he found it to be useful.
But in many other applications
in medical imaging,
the same tricks become
essential because you just
don't have enough data
in the new test case.
And so one makes use of,
for example, the filters
which one learns from an
ImageNet's task, which
is dramatically different from
the medical imaging problems,
and then using those
same filters together
with a new top layer,
set of top layers
in order to fine tune it for
the problem that you care about.
So this would be
the simplest way
to try to hope for a common
representation for transfer
in a deep architecture.
But you might ask, how would
you do the same sort of thing
with temporal data, not
image data, maybe data
that's from language, or data
from time series of health
insurance claims?
And for that you
really want to be
thinking about recurrent
neural networks.
So just to remind you,
recurrent neural network
is a recurrent
architecture where
you take as input some vector.
For example, if you're
doing language modeling,
that vector might be encoding,
just a one-hot encoding of what
is the word at that location.
So, for example, this
vector might be all zeros,
except for the fourth
dimension, which
is a 1, denoting that this word
is the word, quote, "class."
And then it's fed into
a recurrent unit, which
takes the previous
hidden state, combined it
with the current input, and
gets you a new hidden state.
And in this way, you read in--
you encode the full input.
And then you might predict--
make a classification
based on the hidden state
of the last time
[? step. ?] That
would be a common approach.
And here would be a very simple
example of a recurrent unit.
Here I'm using S to
denote in a state.
Often you will see H used
to denote the hidden state.
This is a particularly
simple example,
where there's just a
single non-linearity.
So you take your
previous hidden state,
you hit it with some matrix Ws,s
and you add that to the input
being hit by a different matrix.
You now have a
combination of the input
plus the previous hidden state.
You apply non-linearity
to that, and you
get your new hidden state out.
So that would be an example
of a typical recurrent unit,
a very simple recurrent unit.
Now, the reason why I'm going
through these details is
to point out that the dimension
of that Ws,x matrix is
the dimension of the hidden
state, so the dimension of s,
by the vocabulary size if
you're using a one-hot encoding
of the input.
So if you have a huge
vocabulary, that matrix, Ws,x,
is also going to
be equally large.
And the challenge
that that presents
is that it would lead to
overfitting on rare words
very quickly.
And so that's a problem that
could be addressed by instead
using a low-rank representation
of that Ws,x matrix.
In particular, you could
think about introducing
a lower dimensional bottleneck,
which in this picture
I'm denoting as xt prime,
which is your original xt
input, which is the
one-hot encoding,
multiplied by a new matrix We.
And then your recurrent
unit only takes
inputs of that hidden--
of that xt prime's
dimension, which
is k, which might be
dramatically smaller than v.
And you can even think
about each column
of that intermediate
representation, We,
as a word embedding.
It's a way of--
and this is something that
Pete talked quite a bit
about when we were thinking
about natural language--
when we were talking about
natural language processing.
And many of you would
have heard about it
in the context of
things like Word2Vec.
So if one wanted to take
a setting, for example,
one institution's data where
you had a huge amount of data,
learn every current neural
network on that institution's
data, and then generalize
it to a new institution,
one way of trying to do
that, if you think about,
what is the thing that you chop,
one answer might be, all you do
is you keep the word embedding.
So you might say,
OK, I'm going to keep
the We's, I'm going to translate
it back to my new institution.
But I'm going to let the
recurrent unit parameters--
the recurrent
parameters, for example,
that Ws,s you might allow it
to be relearned for each new
institution.
And so that might
be one approach
of how to use the
same idea that we
had from feed forward networks
within a recurrent setting.
Now, all of this
is very general.
And what I want to do
next is to instantiate it
a bit in the context
of health care.
So since the time
that Pete presented
the extensions of Word2Vec
such as BERT and ELMo,
and I'm not going to--
I'm not going to
go into them now,
but you can go back to Pete's
lecture from a few weeks
ago to remind yourselves what
those were, since the time
he presented that lecture,
there are actually
three new papers
that actually tried
to apply this in the health
care context, one of which
was from MIT.
And so these papers all
have the same sort of idea.
They're going to
take some data set--
and these papers all use MIMIC.
They're going to
take that text data,
they're going to learn
some word embeddings
or some low-dimensional
representations
of all words in the vocabulary.
In this case,
they're not learning
a static representation
for each word.
Instead these BERT
and ELMo approaches
are going to be
learning-- well, you
can think of it as
dynamic representations.
They're going to be a
function of the word
and their context on the
left and right-hand sides.
And then what they'll
do is they'll then
take those representations
and attempt to use them
for a completely new task.
Those new tasks might
be on MIMIC data.
So, for example, these two tasks
are classification problems
on MIMIC.
But they might also
be on non-MIMIC data.
So these two tasks are from
classification problems
on clinical text that didn't
even come from MIMIC at all.
So it's really an
example of translating
what you learned
from one institution
to another institution.
These two data sets
were super small.
Actually, all of these data
sets were really, really small
compared to the
original size of MIMIC.
So there might be some hope that
one could learn something that
really improves generalization.
And indeed, that's
what plays out.
So all these tasks are looking
at a concept detection task.
Given a clinical note,
identify the segments of text
within a note that
refer to, for example,
a disorder, or a treatment,
or something else, which
you then in a second stage
might normalize to the UMLS.
So what's really striking
about these results
is what happens when you go
from the left to the right
column, which I'll
explain in a second,
and what happens when
you go top to bottom
across each one of
these different tasks.
So the left column
are the results.
And these results are
an F score, the results,
if you were to use embeddings
trained on a non-clinical data
set, or said definitely, not
on MIMIC but on some other more
general data set.
The second column
is what would happen
if you trained those embedding
on a clinical data set,
in this case, MIMIC.
And you see pretty
big improvements
from the general embeddings
to the MIMIC-based embeddings.
What's even more striking
is the improvements
that happen as you get
better and better embeddings.
So the first row are
the results if you
were to use just
Word2Vec embeddings.
And so, for example, for
the I2B2 Challenge in 2010,
you get 82.65 F score
using Word2Vec embeddings.
And if you use a very
large BERT embedding,
you get 90.25 F score--
F measure, which is
substantially higher.
And the same findings were
found time and time again
across different tasks.
Now, what I find really
striking about these results
is that I had tried many of
these things a couple of years
ago, not using BERT or
ELMo, but using Word2Vec,
and GloVe, and fastText.
And what I found is that using
word embedding approaches
for these problems didn't--
even if you threw that in as
additional features on top
of other state-of-the-art
approaches to this concept
extraction problem, it did not
improve predictive performance
above the existing
state of the art.
However, in this
paper, here they
use the simplest
possible algorithm.
They used a recurrent
neural network
fed into a conditional
random field
for the purpose of classifying
each word into each
of these categories.
And the feature
represent-- the features
that they used are just
these embedding features.
So with just the Word2Vec
embedding features,
the performance is crap.
You don't get anywhere
close to the state of art.
But with the better embeddings,
they actually obtain--
actually, they improved
on the state of the art
for every single
one of these tasks.
And that is without any
of the manual feature
engineering which
we have been using
in the field for
the last decade.
So I find this to be
extremely promising.
Now you might ask, well, that
is for one problem, which
is classification of concepts--
or identification of concepts.
What about for a
predictive problem?
So a different paper
also published--
what month is it now, May--
so last month in April,
looked at a predicted problem
of 30-day readmission prediction
using discharge summaries.
This also was valued on MIMIC.
And their evaluation
looked at the area
under the ROC curve of
two different approaches.
The first approach, which is
using a bag-of-words model,
like what you did in
your homework assignment,
and the second approach,
which is the top row there,
which is using BERT embeddings,
which they call Clinical BERT.
And this, again, is
something which I had
tackled for quite a long time.
So I worked on these types
of readmission problems.
And bag-of-words model
is really hard to beat.
In fact, did any of you beat
it in your homework assignment?
If you remember, there
was an extra question,
which is, oh, well,
maybe if we used
a deep learning-based
approach for this problem,
maybe you could get
better performance.
Did anyone get
better performance?
No.
How many of you
actually tried it?
Raise your hand.
OK, so one-- a couple of
people who are afraid to
say, but yeah.
So a couple of people
who tried, but not many.
But I think the reason why it's
very challenging to do better
with, let's say, a recurrent
neural network versus
a bag-of-words model
is because there is--
a lot of the subtlety in
understanding the text
is in terms of understanding
the context of the text.
And that's something that
using these newer embeddings is
actually really good at
because they can get--
they could use the
context of words
to better represent what
each word actually means.
And they see
substantial improvement
in performance
using this approach.
What about for non-text data?
So you might ask when we
have health insurance claims,
we have longitudinal
data across time.
There's no language in this.
It's a time series data set.
You have ICD-9 codes
at each point in time,
you have maybe lab test
results, medication records.
And this is very similar
to the market scan data
that you used in your
homework assignment.
Could one learn embeddings
for this type of data, which
is also useful for transfer?
So one goal might be to say, OK,
let's take every ICD-9, ICD-10
code, every medication,
every laboratory test result,
and embed those event types into
some lower dimensional space.
And so here's an
example of an embedding.
And you see how-- this is
just a sketch, by the way--
you see how you might
hope that diagnosis
codes for autoimmune
conditions might
be all near each other
in some lower dimensional
space, diagnosis
codes for medications
that treat some conditions
should be near each other,
and so on.
So you might hope that such
structure might be discovered
by an unsupervised learning
algorithm that could then
be used within a transfer
learning approach.
And indeed, that's
what we found.
So I wrote a paper
on this in 2015/16.
And here's one of the
results from that paper.
So this is just a look
at nearest neighbors
to give you some sense of
whether the embedding's
actually capturing the
structure of the data.
So we looked at
nearest neighbors
of the diagnosis ICD-9 diagnosis
code 710.0, which is lupus.
And what you find is that
another diagnosis code, also
for lupus, is the first
closest result, followed
by connective tissue
disorder, or Sicca syndrome,
which is Sjogren's disease,
Raynaud's syndrome,
and other autoimmune conditions.
So that makes a lot of sense.
You can also go
across data types,
like ask, what is the nearest
neighbor from this diagnosis
code to laboratory tests?
And since we've embedded
lab tests and diagnosis
codes all in the same
space, you can actually
get an answer to that.
And what you see is that these
lab tests, which by the way
are exactly lab tests
that are commonly
used to understand progression
in this autoimmune condition,
are the closest neighbors.
Similarly, you can ask the same
question about drugs and so on.
And by the way, we have made
all of these embeddings publicly
available on my lab's GitHub.
And since the time that
I wrote this paper,
there have been a
number of other papers,
that I give citations
to at the bottom here,
tackling a very similar problem.
This last one also put there
embeddings publicly available,
and is much larger than the one
that we had So these things,
I think, would also be
very useful as one starts
to think about how one can
transfer knowledge learned
on one institution to
another institution
where you might
have much less data
than that other institution.
So finally I want to
return back to the question
that I raised in
bullet two here,
where we looked
at a linear model
with a manually
chosen representation,
and ask, could we--
instead of just naively chopping
your deep neural network
at some layer and
then fine tuning,
could one have learned a
representation of your data
specifically for the purpose of
encouraging good generalization
to a new institution?
And there has been some
really exciting work
in this field that goes by the
name of Unsupervised Domain
Adaptation.
So the setting that's
considered here
is where you have
data from-- you
have data from first some
institution, which is x
comma y.
But then you want
to do prediction
from a new institution
where all you have access
to at training time is x.
So as opposed to the
transfer settings
that I talked about earlier,
now for this new institution,
you might have a ton
of unlabeled data.
Whereas before I was
talking about having
just a small amount
of label data,
but I never talked
of the possibility
of having a large amount
of unlabeled data.
And so you might
ask, how could you
use that large amount
of unlabeled data
from that second
institution in order
to learn representation
that actually encourages
similarities from one
solution to the other?
And that's exactly what these
domain adversarial training
approaches will do.
What they do is they
add a second term
to the last function.
So they're going to minimize--
the intuition is you're
going to minimize--
you're going to try
to learn parameters
that minimize your loss function
evaluated on data set 1.
But intuitively, you're
going to ask that there also
be a small distance, which
I'll just note as d here,
between D1 and D2.
And so I'm being a little
bit loose with notation here,
but when I calculate
distance here,
I'm referring to distance
in representation space.
So you might imagine
taking the middle layer
of your deep neural
network, so taking,
let's say, this layer, which
we're going to call the feature
layer, or the representation
layer, and you're going to say,
I want that my data under
the first institution
should look very
similar to the data
under the second institution.
So the first few layers of
your deep neural network
are going to attempt to
equalize the two data sets
so that they look similar to
another, at least in x space.
And we're going to attempt
to find representations
of your model that get
good predictive performance
on the data set for which
you actually have the labels
and for which the induced
representations, let's
say, the middle layer look very
similar across the two data
sets.
And one way to do that is just
to try to predict for each--
you now get a--
for each data point,
you might actually
say, well, which data
set did it come from,
data set 1 or data set 2?
And what you want is that
your model should not
be able to distinguish
which data set it came from.
So that's what it says,
gradient reverse layer
you want to be
able to-- you want
to ensure that predicting which
data set that data came from,
you want to perform badly
on that loss functions.
It's like taking the
minus of that loss.
And so we're not going to
go into the details of that,
but I just wanted to
give you a reference
to that approach in the bottom.
And what I want to
do is just spend
one minute at the very end
talking now about defenses
to adversarial attacks.
And conceptually
this is very simple.
And that's why I can
actually do it in one minute.
So we talked about how one could
easily modify an image in order
to turn the prediction from,
let's say, pig to airliner.
But how could we change your
learning algorithm actually
to make sure that,
despite the fact that you
do this perturbation, you still
get the right prediction out,
pig?
Well, to think through that,
we have to think through,
how do we do machine learning?
Well, a typical approach
to machine learning
is to learn some
parameters theta minimized
your empirical loss.
Often we use deep
neural networks,
which look a little like this.
And we do gradient
descent where we attempt
to minimize some loss surfaced,
find some parameters theta have
as low loss as possible.
Now, when you think about
an adversarial example
and where they come
from, typically one
finds an adversarial example
in the following way.
You take your same
loss function,
now for specific
input x, and you
try to find some
perturbation delta
to x an additive perturbation,
for example, such
that you increase the loss as
much as possible with respect
to the correct label y.
And so if you've increased
the loss with respect
to the correct
label y, intuitively
then when you try to see,
well, what should you
predict for this
new perturbed input,
there's going to be a lower
loss for some alternative label,
which is why the prediction--
the class that's predicted
actually changes.
So now one can try to find
these adversarial examples using
the same type of gradient-based
learning algorithms
that one uses for learning
in the first place.
But what one can do is you
can use a gradient descent
method now--
instead of gradient
descent, gradient ascent.
So you take this optimization
problem for a given input x,
and you try to maximize
that loss for that input x
with this vector
delta, and you're now
doing gradient ascent.
And so what types of
delta should you consider?
You can imagine
small perturbations,
for example, delta that have
very small maximum values.
That would be an example
of an L-infinity norm.
Or you could say that the
sum of the perturbations
across, let's say, all of the
dimensions has to be small.
That would be corresponding to
like an L1 or an L2 norm bound
on what delta should be.
So now we've got
everything we need actually
to think about
defenses to this type
of adversarial perturbation.
So instead of minimizing your
typical empirical loss, what
we're going to do is
we're going to attempt
to minimize an adversarial
robust loss function.
What we'll do is
we'll say, OK, we
want to be sure that no matter
what the perturbation is
that one adds the
input, the true label y
still has low loss.
So you want to find
parameters theta which
minimize this new quantity.
So I'm saying that
we should still
do well even for the worst-case
adversarial perturbation.
And so now this would be
the following new learning
objective, where we're
going to minimize over
theta with respect to
the maximum of our delta.
And you have to restrict the
family that these perturbations
could live in, so if
that delta that you're
maximizing with respect
to is the empty set,
you get back the original
learning problem.
If you let it be, let's
say, all L-infinity
bounded perturbations
of maximum size of 0.01,
then you're saying we're
going to allow for a very
small amount of perturbations.
And the learning
algorithm is going
to find parameters theta such
that for every input, even
with a small perturbation
to it, adversarially chosen,
you still get good
predictive performance.
And this is now a new
optimization problem
that one can solve.
And we've now
reduced the problem
of finding an adversarial robust
model to a new optimization
problem.
And what the field
has been doing
in the last couple
of years is coming up
with new optimization
approaches to try
to solve those problems fast.
So, for example, this paper
published an ICML in 2018
by Zico Kolter and his student--
Zico just visited
MIT a few weeks ago--
what it did is it
said, we're going
to use a convex relaxation
to the rectified linear unit,
which is used in many deep
neural network architectures.
And what it's going to do
it's then going to say,
OK, we're going
to think about how
a small perturbation
to the input
would be propagated in terms
of getting how much that could
actually change the output.
And if one could be
bound at every layer
by layer how much a small
perturbation affects
the output of that
layer, then one
could propagate
from the very bottom
all the way to the loss
function of the top
to try to bound how much the
loss function itself changes.
And a picture of what you
would expect out is as follows.
On the left-hand side here,
you have a data point,
red and blue, and
the decision boundary
that's learned if you didn't do
this robust learning algorithm.
On the right, you have now--
you'll notice a small square
around each data point.
That corresponds to a
maximum perturbation
of some limited amount.
And now you notice how the
decision boundary doesn't
cross any one of those squares.
And that's what would be found
by this learning algorithm.
Interestingly, one can
look at the filters that
are learned by convolutional
neural network using
this new learning algorithm.
And you find that
they're much more sparse.
And so this is a very
fast moving field.
Every time a new
adversarial attack--
every time a new adversarial
defense mechanism comes up,
someone comes up
with a different type
of attack, which breaks it.
And usually that's from
one of two reasons.
One, because the defense
mechanism isn't provable,
and so one could try to come
up with a theorem which says,
OK, as long as you
don't perturbate
more than some amount, these are
the results you should expect.
The other flip of the coin
is, even if you come up
with some provable
guarantee, there might
be other types of attacks.
So, for example, you
might imagine a rotation
to the input instead of
an L-infinity bounded norm
that you add to it.
And so for every new
type of attack model,
you have to think through
new defense mechanisms.
And so you should expect to see
some iteration in the space.
And there's a website
called robust-ml.org,
where many of these attacks and
defenses are being published
to allow for the academic
community to make progress
here.
And with that, I'll
finish today's lecture.